-Hey, guys.
Mother's Day is coming up,
and in honor of that,
we've teamed up with Samsung
to celebrate some very special
supermoms all week long.
We asked people to nominate
an epic mom in their life --
could be your mom
or a mom you know --
just an amazing person who's
gone above and beyond
to support their families
and friends and communities,
especially through
this past year.
So here's what we did.
We set up video chats
with the moms and we told them
it was for NBC's Instagram.
What we didn't tell them was
that I was going to call them
on my new Samsung Galaxy
S21 Ultra 5G phone
and surprise them with something
to make their Mother's Day
a little brighter.
Tonight's mom is Dedria Jackson.
She's an assistant principal at
Kipling Elementary School
in Chicago, Illinois.
She was nominated by
her friend Laura.
Check this out.
♪ "Tonight Show"
Supermom Surprise ♪
-Hi, my name is Laura, and my
friend Dedria is a supermom
because she's a mom.
She's a grandmother, too.
She's an assistant principal.
It's a Chicago public school
and it's extremely diverse
and low-income.
Dedria supported ensuring that
teachers, parents, and students
could access remote learning
and work to ensure that
all of the staff at her
elementary school
were able to obtain vaccines to
return to school safely.
She steps up, even when she's
not asked to --
that's what a mom does.
It's so much more than
just being a mom.
-D?
-Yes?
-D, are you there?
Dedria? Wait, let me --
Let me turn my video on.
Dedria!
-Hi!
-D, you're a supermom.
Everything that you do
for the school.
And I wanted to thank you
for being a supermom,
and our friends at Samsung
wanted to thank you, as well.
So we'd like to give you
this package --
it's a Galaxy Samsung package.
You get the brand new watch,
you get the Tab,
you get the earbuds,
you get it all!
-Thank you!
-From Samsung.
Congratulations.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God! How awesome is that!
-Dedria, one more thing.
Samsung wanted to give you
a check for $25,000.
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughs ]
-What?!
-You are a supermom
and we wanted to thank you.
-Oh, my gosh!
-[ Laughs ]
-Are you serious?!
-[ Laughs ] Yeah!
-Oh, my God.
-Happy early Mother's Day!
Love from the "Tonight Show".
Congratulations and thanks
for everything you do.
-Both: Thank you!
-Thank you so much!
-Oh, my God!
-Aww.
-My thank you to Dedria
and Laura,
Samsung, and all the supermoms
out there!